pour cause de grève demain plusieurs
associations dont le MRAP ont décider de
commémorer avec un jour d'avance l'un
des événements les moins connus de la
guerre d'Algérie l'effet remonte au 17
octobre 1961 au Quartier Latin une
manifestation de musulmans d'Algérie a
été réprimée avec une incroyable
violence par les forces de l'ordre bilan
officiel selon le préfet de police de
l'époque Maurice Papon TR morts le bilan
a été en réalité
beaucoup plus
lourd en réalité il y en a eu au minimum
200 et je pense que la réalité tourne
probablement autour de 300 des morts
sous quelle forme les un grand nombre de
morts par noyade des morts tués par
balle des morts dans des lieux
d'internement notamment au Palais des
Sports de la Porte de Versailles dans la
cour de la préfecture de police dans
l'enceinte même de la préfecture de
police au stade de Coubertin on a tué
des h dans des lieux d'internement ce
jourl les associations qui célèbr ce
soir ce sinistre anniversaire Souhait
ainsi lutter contre le racisme en
rappelant l'existence du drame un drame
qui ne figure c'est ce qu'elle souigne
dans aucun manuel scolaire traitant de
la guerre
[Musique]
d'Algérie